One of my first forays into genital studies
was looking at ducks.
I discovered that they have
this incredibly dramatic erection.
In a third of a second, the male averts a
20 centimeter long penis and ejaculates.
And this is something that was certainly not known
and that nobody would have guessed in a million years.
The next question that popped into my mind was:
I wonder what the females look like because
you can't have a penis like that without
having something going on in the female.
And when I dissected them I almost fell off my chair
literally because there it was,
this incredible labyrinth of structures in the vagina.
And when we look at the histology of the female ducks
we can see that the females have much thicker
vaginal walls and so essentially they
have reinforced their vaginas
in order to be able to withstand these
ballistic penises without rupturing,
which is of course important if you're a female duck.
And so we emailed somebody who works on ducks
for the industry you know more
the commercial side of it.
We said :"Have you ever seen these weird structures?"
And he wrote back and he said:
"Wow, I cannot believe it."
This is, you know,
this has been here all along, obviously.
But the way he would dissect the females,
he would always just skip through right?
Whereas the way I was dissecting it was:
I was unwrapping it, because I figure
I gotta see what's underneath.
And so I just couldn't believe it.
But it was, I think in part because I was
coming in as a woman.
I was asking a question that to me
seemed pretty obvious right?
and it just apparently hadn't been obvious
to anybody else up until then.